[whispering] I'm inside one of the
Inchindown oil tanks,
an old oil storage facility
in Inverness, in Scotland.
This tank is 237 metres long
and it's not meant for humans.
When it was in use by the Royal Navy
all this colossal space
would have been filled with fuel oil.
With these oil tanks, the Royal Navy
accidentally created
the greatest reverberation chamber
in the world.
Flat surfaces
enclosed by solid rock,
and a chamber big enough that
sound takes a whole second or more
to go off the far wall
and bounce back.
But still narrow enough
that you get lots of reverberation
from all the close surfaces as well.
- The construction started in 1938
and it carried on right through
the beginning of the war
up to around about 1943.
The Admiralty had decided that they
required bomb-proof storage for their oil.
So they set about building a number
of oil tanks across Britain.
And this, Inchindown, is one of them.
The construction required
six tanks to be built.
The entire complex could easily contain
100,000 tonnes of fuel
but one single Royal Navy battleship
can drink 5,000 tonnes.
So it could go very, very quickly.
It is a truly amazing chamber of sound,
a cathedral of oil and
a cathedral of sound.
- So now I'm going to shut up for a bit.
Preston here is going to
fire a starting pistol,
a very, very loud bang.
On the screen is a visual
display of that sound.
Different frequencies will reverberate
for different amounts of time
so you will see that and hear that.
And as it gets quieter
we will turn up the level
on the microphone so it's
easier for you to hear.
Right, everyone ready?
Thank you to the Bannerman Group
for letting us into the tunnels,
to Allan, Alan and Preston
for helping with everything here,
to Matt Gray who is behind the camera
and who's had some musical
experiences over on his channel.
Go for it.
Aagh!
That is terrifying.